we're joined now by ian bremmer
president and founder of eurasia group
he's covered russia for three decades
ian good morning
you you call the biden you call the
biden putin summit
a modest success ian how so
well i mean incredibly low expectations
let's keep that in mind
nothing blew up as as you just said the
ambassadors have been reinstated
you now have consultations there on on
issues like
cyber security and arms control that are
going to go forward
russia is a power in decline but they
are
the largest nuclear power in the world
along with the united states
we haven't fixed that problem we used to
engage with them seriously when they
were the soviets on arms control
we weren't doing that uh over the past
years we need to again now
that's a useful thing but i'm not very
optimistic never mind biden's lack of
confidence i i'm quite skeptical
that we're going to make progress with
the russians on cyber for example which
is the most
important challenge that the two
countries have right now why are you
skeptical about about
getting putin's cooperation on on the
cyber issue
well a couple reasons uh first because
uh putin in the press conference
a complete denial that there was any
involvement or
anything that the kremlin had to do with
the issue secondly the fact that
i think that biden's willingness
to engage in serious deterrence and make
the kremlin pay
for the cyber attacks the ransomware
attacks that are hitting the us
companies
and companies around the world just not
in russia with reckless abandon
i don't think russia thinks it's
credible in other words i don't think we
have to wait for a couple months to see
what the russian response is going to be
i think over the coming weeks
you're going to see a lot more
ransomware attacks including against
critical infrastructure
and then the question is not going to be
did they have a meeting that was useful
the question is
how is gonna biden gonna respond given
that meeting
and will the americans be able and
willing
to make the kremlin pay a price that
makes them pay attention right now
words are not gonna get president putin
uh
to behave in a way that the
international community would find
acceptable that's pretty clear so you
don't expect
putin to cooperate what what what are
you was this a win for putin in some way
this summit
he wanted the meeting a lot more than
the americans
did his country is in decline in around
his region they're losing influence with
governments everywhere in part because
of mass dissent and support for liberal
democracy
in places like belarus for example in
ukraine and moldova the baltics
in part because the chinese are vastly
more influenced influential
in places like central asia so putin's
position is horrible
he really wanted to be seen on that
global stage with biden
the russian state media portrayed that
as a win
having said that because the u.s had the
stronger hand
biden ensured that the meeting went the
way he wanted it to
putin showed up first biden's the one
that came after
biden gave the last word in the press
conference the optics
were favorable to the united states
that's helpful all right ian bremmer
thank you very much